it's amazing you know to win a
championship at home I mean it's a great
filler to win the championship period is
a great filler but to win it for these
fans you know they've been so loyal to
us you know to come home all your family
here all your friends here dubnation
here I mean it's an incredible thing it
doesn't matter where you win you know we
want in Cleveland two years ago which
was fantastic but it's special at home
at the moment you know that last minute
when it was apparent we were going to
win was just incredible no to support we
have every single night and just know
that we had the best home court
advantage in the league feels great I
started playing in the NBA in 1988 and
every time I came to Golden State came
to Oakland in this building the fans
were so awesome and the teams were lousy
basically you know they had some decent
teams but for the most part a lot of bad
teams but the energy in this building
was always so impressive and so these
are loyal fans they love basketball and
it means so much to us and our team and
our organization to be able to give them
this this great product this great team
a great group of individuals and makes
me happy that all the fans here can can
enjoy it
you know every night you step in here
you know even when I would watch games
when I was still in college on high
school and you know the Warriors would
be on TV because they were the only team
playing late they weren't good this
thing was rocking and you know they
stuff through all the tough times and
they stayed true to us and we thank them
for them